crece la polémica en argentina con el
caso de las vacunas vip y hasta 70
personalidades fueron vacunadas
supuestamente antes de tiempo según la
prensa local el ministerio de salud
operó con un circuito paralelo de hasta
tres mil vacunas que tenía como base el
hospital posadas en el área
metropolitana de la capital es una
indignación total lo que utilizan a
nuestros hospitales a la salud pública
para demostrar una pantalla que bueno
ahora sale al alumno
el negocio el gran negocio que para ello
fue en esta pandemia la enfermedad
nosotros estamos en lista de espera
esperando la vacunación
desde el mes de diciembre el escándalo
salió a la luz después de que el
periodista horacio verbitsky confesara
que fue vacunado y afecta a grandes
nombres el principal es el presidente
alberto fernández que recibió una dosis
de sputnik be junto a varios miembros de
su equipo fernández condenó que alguien
se adelante en la vacunación pero
advirtió que el escándalo mediático es
una payasada asegurando que él se vacunó
para dar ejemplo mire si hay más
responsables y van a tener lo que se
tienen que ir
porque nunca me promovía vale nada de
eso pero también digo no voy a hacerme
cargo del escarnio público que están
promoviendo
sin mi vida en argentina la lista
también apunta al ministro felipe solá y
su equipo y al titular de la cartera de
economía martín guzmán además de al ex
presidente interino eduardo duhalde y su
familia o destacados periodistas
embajadores y diputados el ex ministro
de salud ginés gonzález ya renunció por
su implicación en el caso el viernes
pasado y ahora mismo está siendo
investigado por un fiscal este tipo de
escándalos no son nuevos en américa
latina en perú hasta 470 personalidades
fueron salpicadas por el vacuna gay